all right so this next speaker we
probably have all heard of him or used
one of his fabulous packages because he
creates a lot of amazing stuff
and
i've had the pleasure of
eating of him all around the world we're
both really big eaters
but i've never everyone knows that about
me right i mean like food but i've never
been so scared being between someone and
teramy sue before
it was frightening please welcome max
hi how you doing
thanks for coming
um also everybody who's here virtually
thanks for sticking around till like you
know the
end of the day on the second day uh
appreciate you being here
so okay so we're going to talk about um
monitoring after you've built your model
so that's what we're going to talk about
today
slides are here on github if you want
them i'll tweet that out a little bit
so here's the thing you've done all this
great stuff you've built this amazing
model you've solved the company's woes
you've you know you've excelled at what
you're trying to do
and you know what do you do now and so
in most situations
um
you know you want to do all the post
modeling activities otherwise known as
like model operations usually and you
know i used to do this in my last job a
lot
timer i'm sorry
um
don't mind
the help
um
uh and you know
we we used to have a lot of we would
publish models internally with like an
internal system but the consumers of
those models were very very technically
savvy and they were very eager to know
about like what happened just don't give
me a number so we had to spend a lot of
like copious amounts of time describing
like which data did we use how much was
there which predictors you know there's
obvious stuff like you know what was
your model performance but you know we
had to do a little bit about like the
development of the model and that model
documentation really really pays off um
especially if you're in a situation
where um the the number's just not
getting fed into some other subsystem
and nobody ever sees it so you know
there's there's these things called
model cards uh which seem like a really
good um
like first like template for ways of
describing what your model did okay so
if you're doing this in your
productionizing models it's really
critical that you document your model
but it's a bit like writing
documentation for functions nobody
really wants to do it
okay so it's pretty important
um
so
so once you've documented your model
then you probably want to deploy it and
monitor it so let's talk about just
deployment for a minute this is not a
deployment
talk
but you probably have some like really
amazing
exciting
like really revolutionary software that
you might think about using
for deploying your model so if you
haven't seen this we just kind of
released this the other day
it's for rn python and it's called
vetiver this is not a vet of her talk
but you know having spent a lot of time
thinking about model deployment
um and how we do things or how people
generally want things
julia silgy and her team have been
spending a lot of time on you know how
to stash a model somewhere version it
um give a rest api for predictions you
know there's templates for the model
card and so on so if if this is
something you're interested in
i feel like it's a problem when i look
at any solution for model deployment
they all seem to be over engineered for
the wrong things the things we don't
really care about and so everyone i've
either used or looked at or tried to use
i felt like
oh this is not a great experience so
vetiver was really designed to be pretty
seamless and pretty much
doing the things that we think is like
really important to focus on so there's
that
so
once you've productionized it you know
you start getting data in and hopefully
some of that data you'll get labels on
and so if you do have like the true
value and your prediction you can start
doing monitoring over time and so the
idea would be that you know you you
deploy a model you start using it but
maybe at some point it's not really
working as well as it did when you first
published it and so um so you might see
performance sort of drift from a
baseline value
um that like that you calculated when we
first built a model and so
it's a little bit pedantic and i if
you've seen my talks i usually have like
wall of technical detail and i usually
don't have like the one sentence on a
slide
but really the the crux of what i want
to initially say is this
that we talk about model drift all the
time and there's actually really no such
thing as model drift it's impossible to
have model drift and and so we use that
term a lot and you might say like well
okay
like maybe i'll accept that um but you
know words have a lot of meaning
sometimes and i worry about like if we
talk about a model drifting and we want
to solve that problem then there's a
focus because we call it that to make
that a problem for the model but it's
actually not a model problem at all
because the thing is
your model static once you've built the
model unless you're about to retrain it
or update it even if it's like a
bayesian model where you're like
sampling from a posterior the model
itself at that point is done it's like
an amber right so so the model is not
going to like your regression
coefficients aren't going to like
silently change in the night and do
something so you know the point is it's
not really so much about the model
that's like a filter like a piece of
glass it's like the the light you're
shining through the model if that's
changing what comes out of that model is
the thing that you care about and so
really it's the inputs we should be
really really focusing on and you might
you might think about it from the
perspective
of i'll keep using the word uh
applicable here um what you want to see
is if your data are changing
substantially over time and the model is
not really knows how to compensate for
that then your your all your performance
metrics and everything those are the
things that are really drifting but it's
not your model's fault your model is
really not to blame and so the one way
you can think about this is at what
point are my is my model not applicable
for the type of data that i'm receiving
in the wild now that may be different
than what i had when i first built the
model
so it turns out that and this has
probably been reinvented
in many different places but i most know
these types of methods is these these
things called applicability domain
models so i used to work in drug
discovery did a lot of modeling
with computational chemists and they
pretty much have i think they're like
you know a couple years ahead of
everybody in terms of deploying and
managing models and they had this idea
that you want to somehow characterize
the domain of data that your model is
applicable okay and there's a bunch of
different ways you could do that the
main way that people usually think about
it is let's measure some
let's find some way to characterize or
quantify how far we're extrapolating
from our training set so that you know
there's the assumption that if you have
a data point it's really nothing like
your training set that that you know
that data point might be kind of sus
right so you don't know because you
don't know the true value but most of
the applicability domain metrics and
models are really about measuring
extrapolation now a harder thing you can
do with applicability domains and
there's not that many methods to do this
are
have an applicability domain model that
sort of understands where your model
just doesn't predict well regardless of
where the data was so even if it's
something you have a data point that's
like something in your training set
there might be areas of your training
set that just don't fit well and there
are some applicability domain methods
that sort of try to quantify that and
give you like a little heads up that you
know you're not in a good place for your
model
so you know this is not like really like
a terribly new idea there's anomaly
detection there's one class
classification there's a bunch of other
places where methods like these but the
interesting thing here is it's it's a
secondary piece of information that goes
along with your model prediction to tell
you how much you should really think
about using it or how much trust you
should put in it so it's more like a
credibility thing
so really what we'll focus on is the
primary like way to think about this is
applicability domain methods really try
to characterize where your data
mainstream is and the data in question
is really your training set and then
when you get a new data point whether
it's your test set or some data point
like two weeks or two years later how
much does that new data point resemble
or how similar is it to my original
training set
so there's a bunch of different ways you
can do this the two simplest things you
could do are like linear methods
principal component analysis and hat
matrix if you remember the like the hat
matrix is something that like i
mentioned yeah i remember my
my like regression teacher mentioning
something about a hat
but they're basically like linear
methods to measure how far
your data are from like the center of
your training set and with pca that's
actually a it's a fairly elegant way to
do that because when you run principal
component analysis on your training set
especially if there's correlation
the the resulting components have a nice
usually have a fairly
[Music]
nice distribution and it's really easy
to calculate the distance
with a new point
to the center of your uh your pca
components for your training set so
those are two like sort of standard ways
of doing it um again there's like one
class classification two case data depth
is something i learned about like about
10 years ago which he wrote um a bunch
of methods that really like her umbrella
around like metabolomis i can never say
it right uh distance and a couple of
other interesting ways to say like where
in my distribution does any particular
data fall even if it's a very
multivariate distribution that's pretty
cool
the thing i'll talk about just briefly
is isolation forests the nice thing
about isolation forests is they tend to
be you know relatively fast and they can
really
compensate for non-linear trends so if
you're fitting like a big non-linear
model you might not want to do pca or
hat values because you're really
measuring similarity in a like a linear
way and you might be using a non-linear
model that doesn't think about this the
training set that way so that might not
be a bad way of going about things
so you built this thing called an
applicability domain model which is like
a secondary model and then you can score
new samples with it and if you want to
do that a few years ago we had a great
intern at our studio marley who wrote a
package called applicable that has a lot
of this stuff in it
we have a we have a version that's
should be on cran soon once we figure
out like what their issues is with a doi
reference that's like the kind of thing
that holds up a transmission
um that's a good time but if you want to
learn more we have
some about this in the tiny models book
in chapter 17
so you can you can read more there and
um and there's some references at the
end
so isolation force is actually a pretty
to me like novel idea is you've probably
seen like random forests and like
decision trees um and this and what
isolation forests do is they much like a
tree they find predictors within your
data set and they make splits of that
predictor and then sort of like
hierarchically make those splits down
the line and probably until like you run
out of data but the difference with an
isolation force is the predictors are
chosen at random and the split points
are chosen at random so it's like a
randomly generated hierarchy
you know like a tree based model and the
idea is like on this point over here we
have like a red dot there is you if you
have a data point that's like in the
middle of your training set
that it measures basically how many
splits there's a bunch of ways to do it
but you can think about it like it's
looking at how many splits do i have to
make in the data until i isolate that
particular point and since that red
point is surrounded by a bunch of other
data you're going to have to do like a
lot of cutting of that dimension over
and over and over again to get that
point to be the only data point within a
terminal node of the tree and if you
have a data point over here like in
black
um since it's outlying and there's not
much data for it there's probably far
fewer splits that you would randomly
take
to to isolate that point because it's
just not close to anything and so an
isolation force
you know it uses randomness in the
splits and you might do like a couple
thousand trees in your forest and then
it has an output that's like a measure
of like outlier-ness of a data point so
they're really good for like looking for
anomalies or seeing if things are not
like the original data set that was used
to build the isolation forest and just
for kicks that's the one i'm going to
use because it to me is pretty
interesting
so that's what we'll do it's it's also
available and applicable
we'll look at an example in just a
second you y'all i mean it seems like
this conference there's been a lot of
sports data and i'm
i'm gonna like be the finishing touch on
that uh so the example i'm gonna use is
for my beloved pittsburgh penguins if
anybody knows anything about hockey i
keep somebody keeps telling me that
there's like a different penguins
emblem that's on hats and stuff but this
is the one that i grew up on and it's
the only one i will whose existence i
will acknowledge
um
i i one time on ebay i was like oh i
need to get one of those hats before
like you can't get them anymore and i it
was like three dollars i bought on ebay
and i really later realized when they
sent it to me it was like a case of them
so i i took it to pittsburgh to go to
all my old relatives and i'd divvy them
all out and i have one left anyway
um so i have some data it's in the way i
put it in a github repo
i took data from pittsburgh penguins
when they were playing um and and parsed
a couple seasons worth of nhl data
through their api
i had to do some calculations because
there's interesting things about the
data the api doesn't give you like
they'll tell you if a shot is is during
a power play or i'm sorry they'll tell
you the goal is during the power play
but not a shot so i actually went and
re-implemented the arcane
decision tree of um given a penalty
happened here
was this shot during a power play so we
have data on the shot like where it was
taken was it during a power play
uh you know where was what stadium
against what team we have information on
the players
like who it was like what position you
know the game time and so on you can
imagine and so i decided to make an
outcome
um whether a shot was on goal or not so
a shot would be on the shot would not be
on goal is if you missed the the goal
entirely or if it was blocked by
defender and then an on goal shot would
be something that we either went in the
net or was touched by the goaltender and
so it's about a 50 50 class of balance
and i won't bore you with all the the
stuff because honestly i'm going to use
this data set so much it's going to be
like new iris by the time i see you next
year
and i build a boosted tree and i'm just
sick of talking about xgb boost so i did
light gbm just for kicks
the data set i used the train was about
twenty six thousand data points i had a
validation set of about six thousand and
a test set of about nine aaron to the rc
curve came back pretty consistent about
point eight i'm kind of happy with this
it's not a bad model fit um especially
for teaching
and so you know what we might do is we
might say like okay if i work for the
penguins and i'm listening if you want
to call me pittsburgh um
you know you might build models like
these to say like oh if if so and so is
taking shot here during short-handed
game three situation you know what's the
what's the chances that you're even
gonna get that shot on goal so it's not
like an unreasonable thing you might
want to predict
so what i did is i took that training
set
there's a bunch of different like
variations of ways you could do this but
i just built an isolation force model
and then what i did is you know
everything has to be relative to the
training set when you do this
and so um
so what i did is i just repredicted the
training set so that i can look at the
outlier-ness of every individual point
that i use to build a model and so on
the right hand side here we have this
like empirical distribution function
that on the x-axis is the score that
comes out of an isolation force which
larger valor larger values mean it's
more of an anomaly of a data point
whereas values closer to zero means like
your right smack dab in the middle of
the training set and then you can see
here that um
that for example if we get a score of
about 0.35 about 39 of the training set
samples were less extreme than that so
you can imagine that if you got you know
these numbers are relative so that's why
i like doing them in terms of
percentiles because if i told you my my
isolation 4 score was 0.4 you'd be like
okay like there's no like in there's no
obvious interpretation of that so what
we do is we we make a reference
distribution of the training set and
then we score new data we look at the
percentile and say okay relative to the
training set this is a really extreme
value if the percentile is pretty high
so for example if i if i had a shot
that was associated with a
isolation force score of about 0.45
there were almost no data points that
were more extreme than that one because
that has a very high percentile so it's
kind of like a way to standardize the
notion of what's extreme relative to
your training set
and so what i did is i took the next
season
and for every game i computed all the
the
applicability scores and in this plot
every data point is a game and they
usually have about like 100 150 shots
per game and i just plotted here like
the mean um percentile and so you can
see like the first game of the season
the mean value is about 0.25 and each
game has its own variation here so some
of the variations very wide some of them
are fairly tight but on average um on
the first game most of the shots were
exactly like the data we used to build
the model but then you can quickly see
maybe after the third game we have like
one of the most extreme situations
where very few of any of the shots that
we had during that third game were were
like anything like we had in the
training set and so what we would
normally do is there's going to be up
and down bounces and so on but we
basically would like to monitor this or
some statistic like this
over time to look and see where like my
applicability domain model is telling me
hey you know if it's going in one
direction like you're moving further and
further away from your training set and
then you know that would be a trigger
for you to go back and say okay okay we
should rebuild our model let's take the
data that we've labeled since we built a
model put that in maybe take some of the
order data out whatever we want to do
rebuild the model so it's more relevant
for the type of data that we're getting
like here and now and so you know you
can see it's not a great example maybe
for the talk you can see it's sort of
trending upwards um but there is a lot
of variation here so maybe like around
around january you know if i were doing
this i would probably say to myself like
i should just take all this data and
just retrain
and then redo everything
maybe with better
um
and uh and then you know rebuild the
model because it seems like it's a good
time to do this
um so when i worked in when i worked in
drug discovery we we would basically
whenever we could apply like
applicability domain um value to every
prediction so a chemist would say like
oh i like this you know i've on my
computer designed this chemical i think
it's really good for whatever it is we
wanted to make it good for
we get that equation for the chemical
out they push it through like the
modeling systems that are deployed and
then you get a prediction back saying
like i don't know there's like a
the
oh it's a good example the permeability
value for this is like 0.3 and chemists
would want to use that but we would also
attach basically like almost like a red
light green light kind of thing
um
they called it a confidence score that
kind of drove me nuts because it's not
like a confidence interval but it was
basically applicability domain model so
if you get a if you get a prediction
back at 0.3 but it's got like a red
light next to it you can be like maybe i
shouldn't really think about that data
point so much and i should maybe have
that compound synthesized and test it
for real instead of letting the model
predict it
so with these data if you were to do
that um here are the the two most
anomalous shots in the subsequent season
one is a shot at minute or minute 35
which was a power play it was sydney
crosby who's the center and this one
makes a little bit of sense it's nine
feet so this is like
euclidean distance from the goal and
it's at a fairly oblique angle like 60
uh 63 degrees so he's almost it's not 90
degrees but he's you know he's almost
like
um from the y-axis like level the goal
um and and there just weren't many shots
in the training set that were probably
at that angle
and um
and distance uh by sidney crosby the
next one i don't really have any way to
tell you why this one came up to be so
anomalous it could be that this
particular player
maybe maybe they acquired him late and
he didn't have that many shots in the
training set
but i couldn't really tell you why the
second one seems so egregious
and so with those you know you might
want to warn the user like hey we can
think about models is you can always get
a prediction right you really have no
idea whether that prediction is any good
and so applicability domain methods are
really built behind trying to give you
some sense of whether you should believe
it or not
and then if you were looking for
something that's like the most mundane
prediction here's one at the bottom here
where the score is about 0.56
it's 39 minutes into the game
short-handed
by defenseman 25 feet angle 21 degrees
is not that
remarkable so um i could kind of see why
that one's not a big deal in terms of
the applicability domain
so overall if you want to learn more
here's a link that has like a google
scholar link and here are the the main
review papers that i've looked at over
the years which are actually pretty good
but the whole idea of this is like we
again we're always thinking about model
drift because we're always like the
model the model the model but in this
case it's data and we need to find some
way to know what's coming into our model
and if the population that we think
we've been predicting is changing over
time so so for example if you're doing
some sort of like promotional like
advertising and you're trying to predict
like who's going to take a promotion you
know it could be that you have a new
population of people that are coming
into the system and you just don't have
many of them so you want to know when
things are changing sort of underneath
your feet and so whether it's
applicability domain method or something
else it's like you know just like
characterizing market segments or
something like that and trying to model
them
you know have something that's measuring
your data performance statistics that
come out after the fact are also great
and they're probably the best thing you
can do but knowing why performance is
not doing well is probably a really good
thing and these types of models would
make you go back and say like okay but
why is this anomalous and you can
untangle that and figure out what's
happening which will then of course
inform you about what you should be
doing on the next model fit
or what maybe you want to enrich your
training set for the population that
you're encountering now so that's a
general gist
thank you for coming
[Applause]
i don't know if that went if that just
hit zero i didn't see it trust me it was
okay down to the second we need to get
like a negative countdown timer because
when people know how much they go start
blinking at me yeah exactly they blink
it gets a lot flashier and flashier
all right cool thank you and he can't go
anywhere because he's gonna have to
autograph his book so we could give it
away
we hear that you hear that they're
excited no they're moaning because if
they get it it's like four pounds
they're like
these are two springer books
now this one is much more substantial
what is that yeah
holy [ __ ] holy crap
here take a look at biostats
that's your used to be your field how
many pages is that
really yeah i wanted to use cheaper
paper for you
902 oh yours is 5.99
this is not just cheaper that sounds
like nicer paper too though
it eclipses that
so this one again is gonna go to one of
your bio folks we're just gonna find a
way to get it to you but that one